[Applause]
[Music]
you're wearing leather this is cool
everything you have it's even cooler on
the in Superman sheets cheese has only
prominent eyes I turned this jacket
inside out when I travel when I sleep it
on the plane yeah outside out looks like
I brought my Superman bedsheets you're
saying that's a problem well it's a
problem you walk by I think it's cool
you know what we call those people fools
this you cut your jam Jim she's lining
your awesome rock-and-roll jacket and
you go it's time for Rodriguez to dream
up the next thing what about Jay dad
he's pretty sweet yeah he's a just a
creative force you'd give anything and
you can just make it work yeah we shot
once upon Tyne Mexico with him and eight
days old part men eight days he's like
me Seimei I may go may he go
oh good you be your own voiceover I
thought you might need us Antonio
Banderas a Stengel when I start from
dusk till dawn and I bet I bet you get
this from time to time and I hope you
like it I didn't know it was a vampire
that's how we always wanted people to
see isn't that great it's great though
it was amazing you would look at your
tequila on you what happened I likened
it to a like a tomboy taking off her hat
and she had gorgeous hair and boobs the
whole time Salma Hayek is real smoking
yeah thanks for giving the world back
yeah look I mean you had a real vision
and now fur from dusk till dawn the
series whaling this new girl him he's a
Gonzales and she is unbelievable well
sight unseen
almost you have your own network you
Oprah Diddy end of list boom deter Ted
well
yeah I can't make the joke you know
what's weird about your Wikipedia pages
it says your net worth and then weird
does it 38 million no it's on there I
know you made that up I was peeing in
your bathroom I was like I should look
[Laughter]
back in the gun business thought this
had big [__] you have a big guy I hear
you have a big [__]
that's his cook oh I hear you're a big
cup there's no way they would know that
so this is a figure that must be talking
cook you love cooking love to cook with
your big I work a lot out of the home
I'm edit there and I write there sound
mix in the music and you're just being
creative all the time and then you have
to go eat eventually you go you don't
want to break out of that creative mode
so you go down and you cook cuz it's
like art you're gonna eat you make
something great if you eat it you're
satisfied you're still in creative mode
you can go right back up and finish
where you left off it's your deal oh you
want to talk about cooking in a cool way
effortlessly cool no problem you from
all of the guys like us you do you you
cook so good it's like a good bout of
lovemaking yes Antonio Banderas
lovemaking I can cook for 12 hours
straight and if I'm doing slow smoked
brisket you're talking 18 hours with the
wood smoke got a whole time tender
tender what it needs to be done there's
ugh you men suck you sauceless succulent
till the end
oh yeah so yeah we don't want to I mean
I'm surprised you interrupted your
incredible life to do this why so I
pitched my life story to Judd Apatow he
loved it I wonder now that we're such
good friends better friends would you
make it I'm a young man I grew up
religious I went to a religious school I
thought I was gonna be a youth pastor
then I got married in last 22
oh he jumped to the third act already
yeah that's the despot you know what
that's what it's over yes well that's
the trouble isn't it keeping a
compelling third of that go back okay I
didn't you your way what well now I feel
like I need to say that more interested
then the woman the man that she cheated
on me with small Italian man maybe I go
after him in the Rodriguez version maybe
I chase him in a car okay the mistake
you did was earlier it's all your fault
it was my fault my she left me for this
other guy you never won because I don't
know emotional unavailability now you're
making jokes like this all the time
Robert don't you cut me to my course you
tell me we do this movie my wife leaves
me second act I walk into a smoky saloon
you will make the movie we'll make it
don't be much of an audience but we can
make your screen adhere and Tarantino
will be there like I can't do them at
all just you enjoying that word a little
don't just throw that away and then we
come over here
just be good big Robert Rodriguez one of
my favorite filmmakers directors and
just overall artists now I mean you're
incredible thank you so much using the
time the check out does until Donald
plug off will plug all that stuff still
down the series series on over a network
El Rey which means the Sun the Sun know
the king
[Applause]
[Music]